i am loki
of asgard according to tom hiddleston
if you're going to be bad you might as
well be bad with style
the disney plus loki series has brought
us all sorts of different versions of
loki and along with them
a spread of fantastic costumes which
loki had special alterations made to
their costume
which performer went through an
extensive costuming process only to be
seen briefly on screen
let's have a look the conjure new outfit
you have no idea how uncomfortable
something like this is
any fans of the mcu will know that the
majority of the costumes are pretty
complex and
more often than not tight and
restrictive as can be
the role of sylvie played by sophia
dimartino is no exception as we can see
by this
incredible skin-tight suit she wears it
might seem impossible to do anything
really functional when she isn't filming
but
the fact is this outfit actually enables
her to be a bit of a real-life superhero
she rocks her days on set balancing time
as an actor and
mother regularly feeding her child it's
a little bit overwhelming at times
costume designer christine wada made
special alterations for dimartino since
she needed to be able to pump milk and
feed her child between takes on set
wada added concealed zippers on parts of
the costume making it much easier for
the silvia actress to quickly get out of
costume enough on her own so she was
able to attend to her duties as a mother
it was important that it all worked and
it was really practical and comfortable
this small and thoughtful detail was a
game changer for dimartino and sets a
great example for just how accommodating
a costume designer can be when it comes
to creating impressive outfits we see in
the mcu
and beyond dimartino expressed her
thanks to wada online explaining that it
really meant a lot to her to be able to
focus on a job when she needed to
all the while continuing to be a pretty
full-time mom to a young child
as for the loki we all know and love tom
hiddleston
his primary concern was whether or not
he would be in good enough shape to fit
into his old costume
that's right the costume we see him in
is the original from
years ago when hiddleston first took to
the screen in the mcu
fortunately the costumes still fit like
a glove
absolutely not this is fine as guardian
leather
we're guessing it was a solid confidence
booster for the actor
the god of mischief does appear in loads
of brand new outfits as well
with pretty impressive variety no less
how do i look
hiddleston rocks this business looking
outfit right down to the skinny tie
the actor also looks president ready in
his loki 2021 suit
featuring the signature green vest and
golden horns
as for the time variants authority
jumpsuit well let's just say
it's a tough look to pull off but
hiddleston does it pretty flawlessly
it kind of matches the vibes of his hair
which is actually
not his own much to the surprise of many
fans
tom hillson's hair isn't the jet black
we see him sporting in the mcu
while the actor did at one time dye his
hair black the length wasn't where the
team envisioned loki's hair to be
so he needed to wear a wig to bring the
signature black locks to the screen
but you already knew that ever wonder
how hiddleston manages to look so pale
the almost blanched appearance of loki
is courtesy
of all the time in the makeup chair
loads of makeup is put on hiddleston
before filming to change the appearance
of his skin
while these outfits hair and makeup
don't necessarily look that extensive
a surprising amount of time is spent
getting prepared
two hours were spent in the hair and
makeup chair getting everything done
plus about 45 minutes for the costumes
themselves
bootstraps buckles and belts take a lot
more time than we would expect
what exactly makes a loki a loki
independence
authority style
[Music]
so how did owen wilson end up rocking
grey lox's mobius
i'm agent mobius by the way the concept
actually only came up a couple of weeks
before filming and was inspired by an
entirely different production altogether
back when the mobius actor was filming a
project called documentary now
he went through loads of different wigs
one in particular that was
very similar to the hair he has in the
loki series while the wig didn't end up
being used for that project
wilson was a really big fan of the look
and when it came time to take to the mcu
screen
the actor suggested it to the team as a
possible look
the crew said yes and gray-haired mobius
was born
according to wilson the look really
embodies the character
so much so that he and the team have a
hard time imagining mobius looking any
other way
honestly we agree it's the perfect look
for the character
you betrayed me you betrayed me oh grow
up grow up
it isn't just the lead characters that
go through different makeup wig and
costume options to find the perfect look
even smaller day player roles like the
flight attendant actress erica coleman
she went through a much more rigorous
costume experience than we would expect
pullman actually had about four or five
fittings for that one costume alone
which doesn't even get a huge amount of
screen time
is there anything else i can do for you
sir i suppose we'll find out won't we
in an interview the actress shared that
her outfit was in fact
custom made for her this is often the
case across the board
in the mcu there is no shortage of time
work and effort put into every detail of
the production
what kind of detail are we talking about
well coleman said that the adjustments
varied from small things like how high
the neckline should go
to where different pockets should be and
even how many buttons should be attached
the detailed work doesn't just apply to
what we see on the actors though
consideration is put into what actors
wear under their costumes as well
coleman was actually given undergarments
to suit the appropriate time period
we bet she was probably pretty surprised
when she was handed 70s style underwear
by the costume department
as for makeup coleman's stewardess
doesn't seem too complex but that didn't
mean
she wasn't given half a dozen options of
red lipstick to try
in order to find the absolute best tone
of red that would match her outfit and
complete the image
this type of detailed work plays a major
part in establishing these worlds of the
mcu
see you again someday
if this series has shown us anything
it's that there are
in fact loads of loki's which one of us
are you
so how do they compare to the different
iterations of the comics
we've got richard e grant as classic
loki rocking the classic suit that we
all know
he's overly sensitive like the rest of
us the last time we saw this style of
outfit was actually in the halloween
episode of wandavision
when vision appeared wearing a very
similar looking costume
kid loki played by jack veal is part of
the classic loki crew from the comics
appearing in journey into mystery and
young avengers comics
his style is pretty similar to classic
loki we can somewhat see the evolution
from kid to classic between the two
what was your nexus event your majesty i
killed ball
boastful loki aka deobia operae
stands out from all the other loki's in
this darker outfit
while this variant loki prefers to be
called sylvie since loki isn't who she
is anymore
her look in the comics and series are
pretty similar
especially compared to what tom
hiddleston's loki is dressed like
small details on the outfits like the
woven black leather and gold accent on
the chest
make it clear there is a definite
connection it's impressive to see just
how
many details and references the team
manages to include
there's no need to be dramatic but yeah
kind of the mcu has managed to make both
impressive and innovative costumes for
the series
demonstrating just how much goes into
costuming and visuals for a major show
like this
we are also big fans of the inclusion of
throg and alligator loki
who might just be our new favorite loki
which version of loki do you prefer
you